друзі всім доброго вечора та агзам
жданова дэна до нас вісім вечора опція
означає чого платформа та масивного піт
ринку міністерства святі наука та
виходить в ефір і сьогодні ми продовжимо
нашу практику розмиваються fohow ми
психологом і я дам йому українцям метан
державному дітям і владна мила 3 ​​моєму
дуже багато , вигляд вас то зігнутого як з
бригад та психічним здоров'ям рубіном
якийсь за раз розвідданим задіг і
цивільний винь цьому сьогодні ми запиту
вам натали ломоносову але я про таку
ніж психологу травня 22 року про яку
також we are терапевтом то гіпнотерапевт
Віталія доброго вам вечора добрий вечір
ну око на porsche випробування ким ми
задаємо всім нашим гостям це як ви
переживаєте місяць вина ще у вас
вибухнула вбивається я працюю struck
такий член або монтаж mizar
свою історію
розповідала
на третій день я на 4 дай провини нас з
собою взяла
релігійно орли і на громад і хвали
вихідні усикової синагоги
нападали до його будинку та
автобус його на запити у нас собою це я
скакала свій будиночок і сума кого ми
просто стрибнув метою автобусі поїхав
одні куди думав та ви чому молдови до
вправі автобусами з біженцями і там
побоювалася приємно можна намалювати ще
у морі людей і моя
знаємо а знаємо їх так ви і ікл клієнтам
а не писала та й у загальному плані цих не
контакті їх нічого не почав з собою
я згадала сил германії та заразна шкіри
та ссів живу у марійній mizer
техінком від і 4 синіх іваном нас про і
тіла і ми тут ось і
інші ти чекай мене нехай так а
я завалив не матчі з українцями
біженцями чого тут діоди
дуже багато море море наших людей
сьогодні що ми другим
лайку містечку hamburg
алло я бачу наших нових
ну ми на ви раді брат лікарю я в законі і
чистими не м'яч і не звинувачуємо коригуємо
even теж стає їхньому навичкам
вміститися містер каменепаду liquid
нідерландів знаєте там і українські
біженці їх там розумієте та щоб тардіс
на моторшоу тому що для всієї не
мочення характерно класна ось видно так
чого я хотів би з вами поговорити тому
що ваш приклад приклад мільйонів
українців з прикладу про те що сім'ї
роз'єднується in та відразу мільйона та
кричать тобто нідаду Європи очистить
обстрілявши муки тобто знаходиться в
україна алла людина батьку пішов згані
сил України територіальної оборони та
ціну на душі їжі на сторонньому ми
розуміємо, а що там і люди людини
вичавка може поїхати і відра дженева
ціни на місяці і відразу його кується
закінчитися ще й збувається з . зірка
раді на психології cool і ну ось я така
така така машина розставання
розумієте тут справа на туман і просто
вання автома
оу вині або дітей ціна приховуєш там
іжма бути про дітей
до 1 або на як усім вони справлялися з 7
цінатор ситуація далеко і ми були та
готове багаті волосся можна в день має
цьому ж бути обшита рушив рушили
це ти можеш нас примати я знаю ми на
клієнти його не вся кава та іван iii
меншому вигляду носять усі пошуком робіт
бубни видавалася і червоним і ціною з зносу
дах
ncc відразу мило їм право тут побути я
розлучення в тому ще ми хвалимося за ти
хто за вище вся і ті знайти їх те
поїхали от отрута я буду в нас до моєї
будиночки ти ж чуєш seven
ризиковий
[музика]
той серце можуть про небезпеку
жителі смерті я до біса якусь дорогу
вниз slime але ось так у тему у тему
контексті нас правді оновити 2 контекст
розряду тому що
пишеться може будь то історія отримав
в'єтнаму живих це левина і його скований
потавин великий в Україні джеда допомагає
6 а інша історія скарбів школах які
випадки такушки наприклад моя колега
нова людина ризикова і поза червоним
аж до цієї батарейки бучин відомо що
він і виїхав дізнається, а щоб видмухується
людина реально за 1 ну я і потрібно також
ставить
давайте персик є ще ось та ти нас
запитує та так чому його прапором
а я і вона може змінитися і чому воно
там травня травня пляшок з мамою че там
закинути навіщо роду ніж я правильно мамі
в цеху лопатках дієти кума не когось
піна пов'язані мешканець цього
віку
ви бочками ви може вловити і що він у
річку російську нове тільки моя псм і
худа
демониця було наливку добрий лікар все
закласти ж ті образ віку
або ще до піни та
будь-яку
будь-якому випадку
діти вони відчувають усі і вони всі
розуміють
то над рабам не треба приховувати від
дитини
тому треба сказати так як є
тільки при цьому зберігати своє
спокій для цього нам ну допомоги
самому підготуватися і сказати що
відбувається військові дії та
що твій тато зараз нас захищає
захищає нашу країну захищає нашу родину
робить все можливе, щоб ми з тобою
були в безпеці
а ми з тобою тут не тому, що то
тому що так безпечно для тебе
тому що дитині дуже важливо розуміти
що його дорослі можуть про нього
подбати що він оберігаємо це 2
слуга та
відомі деталі шпалери член від риби чи їх
коти
треба а габарити про факти
нам хоч і труби табло замутили
top ten та емоції на кижах там ти
розумієш нам все-таки факти
відбувається це і це ти знаєш був за 1
цент
ніякий прихованих розмір ти знаєш
черга буваєте на нашу країну напав
барах та
краще таки момент дити гарно каже
купа
готові ще pawn та батоги та шаблонів та
на мої будні
той від у нас захищаючи від він захищаючи
візбору вояки на нас напав
скоро закінчиться 2 на 1 їх council а
армія он і душить добрі виражені і
явні при може
вимагати коротко ясно по суті
фактично і завжди закинь чого ти на
бульбашки як тільки жити в психології топ
там зі швидкістю вчитися робомів сем від
душі можу дні і ми можемо у і все буду
добрих і будуть navitel ще краще пакету
відразу мило і
не випадав просто спротт як це більше
нам їсти
бочку ризиковий і дати на там до поспішайте
outwear про вас та нашими дітьми
повернулася та й кожному вона що а вона йшла
батька там
хтось таке, не просто в лоб і не
напишеш і я власне сама на дні
сексу лавкам починаю Наташиного то мені
плану зграя і я ж відправлено дзеркалі
ось цьому протитечі мова
незначною
так
розуміє і треба
я красі сказати
я з гине
ми будемо йому витягни
china штату справ переможний сюди вдома силою
і неушкоджений і ось так краще говорити
тому що ви скажете ні точно ні
ніхто не знає
але треба так подавати що
тато сильні і він там не один і
у нього дуже багато зброї та нашої
сильніше у ворога тому тато зробити все
можливе щоб повернутися додому цілим і
неушкодженим ти ж знаєш який у нас тато
сміливою сильні спритні
знаєш я знаю ти пам'ятаєш як ви з татом
стрибали там грали там все ти знаєш
який потрапити та я знаю все вір у попу
топ топ топ топ м нанести акуму
транслюємо а щодо овочі ми там
скажімо так обіцяємо дуже ранку
шляхи а що до того щоб піна не в силі
свого батька то там українську whiskas до
чому такі думаю ми з поливаємо
здійснитися буду добрий а так ти
прибув ходить або такого прямого
влучення
друга не розуміє ще доріжки і нам
треба бути
гнучким та
power that i таксі за силою ось і його
беру
з одразу мило
один кейс нам на останніх стримах ваших
опинилася в ситуації взаємодії
права ось така плита смак печатку на
себе маску а потім на дітей так що ти
самому сам перебуваєш у такому станіні
мультфільм від жаху комусь дицевич чого
ці c
можна буду знаєте я
дітей що нічого не буває тому що
вулиці будуть бачок і владно проти б
запитати ще як-небудь взуті в нормальному
вуста нікуліну приклад приймаєш диску
за своєю людиною в язичну назватися
таких місій в Україні за раз та просто
знають заслуги потребного з та тут ми
but i ну давайте фмс дозволила боці ти
сама можеш начебто знаку мінусів я
правильно
знаєте є таке прислів'я щоб окопах
і туристів немає треба вірити це
справді єдине, що у нас
їсти ми не можемо напевно сказати і
коли ми висимо повітрі ситуація
невизначеності то самому собі потрібно
допомагати гридо я не знаю але я вірю я
сподіваюся а
до дитини потрібно підходити тоді колись
вже заспокоївся і намагатися вселяти йому
ось своїм голосом тому що неважливо що
ти говориш важливо як ти говориш і
важливо вселяти спокій, але немає нічого
страшного в тому, щоб показати свої
емоції тому що це нормально все
нормально показується боятися плакати
там просто про допомогу і все-таки і she
alive ніби біля веж
у такому матчі на мою повстання ми робимо
один із жінок своїми там по
інформацію і все-таки менше від цього
потрібно уникати тобто намагайтеся як
гриться з подругами або з кимось сусідами
загалом не обговорювати подробиці при дітях
що здається що вас ніхто не чує на
насправді саме в цей момент
відбувається
ось вам ми заряджаємо їх потрібно все
дорослі з дорослими і ось зараз душу
важливі у дітей організовує і такими
я ходжу в мої роки пучком від вас я на
канал сходовому майданчику там 10 до
крику квартир зголений дітей ніби кван і
бути та організовує їх Михайло eurozone там
трохи граєте в гущавині якщо 5 6 то можуть
розум
комп'ютерні ігри також допомагає
зайняті
на ту годину вилиці і ви хоче і тато
каже і щоб вам ти був нам теж
потрібно нам потрібно худенька на результати
свої емоції і розбавляється навіть важливі в
депо проїжджаючи психічну травму краще
перемовляти води менше молода мама
ексудат і побачила з чим мама мама
плаче вдома на та розгону та задає
харчування мамочку ти плачеш я коротше
повис молодець ти все правильно бачиш я
плачу б ми не страшно все нормально
боялися б мені страшного б я не знаю
чи я вірю
не віриш і все буду добрі за раз
поплачу не стану краще
наталі були більше такі широкі
фреймут я думаю що ви і я абсолютно
кожен українець цілий місяць перебуває в
стане новим по стінах стресу тобто
всі туризму мого пара лстк ось для того
щоб ніби з датами і пиздєєєць і навіть
важливі руза раз ти просто там закривати і
сербія but i must скажу так можна 3 та
пафосно лабуду корисливим хештег та ісу
спірс твоє державі і один одному це
можливо а я коли своєї батьківщини так і
там волонтерство так і просто працює
що ти малюєш плати заробітної плати 4
printing вже супер крутим його дати цьому
я тут ніби в ресурсі я ще можна так
сказати і в ситуації cool і нехай її ну
за це обидва новими та й чоловік великому
цінові наївний а я коротше деякі сперечатися
на реальну чикова немає в нас чим і там
завтра психов не знають видно на москву і
зніму так і на інформаційний
вакуум клонів engine та травня і ти
пожинаєш думати ще раз, але виймається
краще налякана і нуцці навіть сильно
вибуває і без ресурсів ось так що до
винний ці ресурси будуть видані equis
панчохи відразу мід ще ресурс по обидва психі
як би треба
окремо від тіла тобто і танці розум і
ось зараз ми
переживаємо це пульс і сукнях з
розуміти акули нормально боятися і
тривожитися нормально і три бога
включає рити та швидкі кліпи поп дінки
перша edge of the bay
будь-яка тварина нелюбина вова ви часто
їж будьте лабуда рятуйся і ціну ліцей
забарвлення класну музику ти включаєшся
думки не відрізняється, але твоя більше
енергійна система сформувалася до
свідомості на баре він роль бога
завдяки цьому ми всі спільно тут
знаходимося
відбувається три основні типу
поведінки 1 якщо є можливість будь-яке
тварина рятуватиметься втечею і це
правильно тому не потрібно себе звинувачувати
якщо у вас є можливість хтось то
є переходити в безпечніше місце
переїжджати виїжджати не треба думати що
це якось взагалі недобре це
правильно другий момент якщо тварина
загнаному кут або якщо наприклад
настільки ти сама володієш що ти
береш відповідальність за це і як би
стаєш головою як був на чолі то
друга стратегія це битися є перше
бігти старе битися до взагалі до
останнього та третя стратегія це
завмерти, а прикинутися мертвим і цей
теж нормальна стратегія всі три
стратегії це стратегії виживання
порятунку життя не потрібне за себе за
це не звинувачувати взагалі не хвалити нічого
тому особливо думати тут нічого
потрібно довіритися тілу те, що ти можеш
то й робити те, що ось-ось тебе є
можливість це і робить і
щодо діяльності
то краще робити те, що в тебе краще
всього виходить дуже правильно сказали
вмієш готувати корми вмієш лікувати личі
вмієш вчитися бери дітей вчив вмієш
займатися дітьми збери їх почни не
займатися тобто в буквальному значенні
потрібно робити те, чого ти не можеш
вгадати і за це ось знайди собі заняття
у чому ти як би можеш допомагати суспільству
на що все суспільство зараз згуртувалося але
ви говорите про те, як знайти в собі
ресурс треба пам'ятати що ресурс ось він
як би в тілі насправді і є
основи сон
перше і найголовніше можеш спати спи
ось є 15 хвилин для закрий очі коли
переживши закритими очима то вже
відпочиваєш
сон обов'язково в будь-який момент коли у
його можливо друге їжа намагайтеся їсти
і пити якомога більше води не
забувайте це питво та гаряча їжа третя
свіже повітря та прогулянки хто особливо
знаходиться наприклад там безкоштовно
відпочити і села в сховищах чи десь у
квартири або що все одно хоча б
навколо будинку хоча б щось зробіть
над собою зусилля чомусь тому що
енергія застряє в тілі в буквальному
сенсі всі м'язи ось так напружуються не
потрібно але не міг ні якщо не
підійти нуб і зробіть присідання
робіть зарядку це дуже важливо ви
допомагаєте собі інакше формується ось ці
все загалом буду розповісти щоб
не формувати їх ще більше загалом про
руху три основні речей сон не так
вода рух на свіжому повітрі ось це
знову такі основи 3 психологічна
основа дуже важлива коли такі речі
відбуваються потрібно розмовляти
вимовляти вимовляти вимовляти
тільки враховуєте кому з ким тобто
краще зі своїм там не знаючи з подругою
або з другом і там і якщо вам є і
дорослі з дорослим ось що а дітям
потрібно пояснює не приховувати, але давати
ось як я сказав вони не емоційно
таку раціонально фактичну інформацію
яка наводить хорошому ось чому ми
це робимо заради безпеки та
все закінчиться добре перемога буде за
нами ти побачиш
ми будемо лацій ось-ось напевно коротко
ось ці речі ще дуже допомагає
звертайте увагу на дихання, тому що
тривожне дихання це грудне дихання
потрібно опускати дихання вниз живота та
дихати прямо м'язами живота зона ви
опускаєте живуть і надуваєте кулю м'язами
живота дихати м'язами живота це
називається діафрагмальне дихання вона
як кнопку включає
парасимпатичну нервову систему
відповідальність за розслаблення за
зниження кров'яного тиску за
зменшення або серцебиття за
розслаблення м'язів на себе дві підсистеми
simpatico яка за збудження та пари
simpatico вони працюють як + замок та
гаряча у збудженому стані все
час як все знаходиться включити ось це
ось розслаблення доставка буває важко
але його включає ось ця сама тварина
дихання животом дихати дихайте животом ти
сісти і навіть просто подихати п'ять хвилин
знижує м'язову напругу знижує
кров'яний тиск зменшується частоту
серцевих скорочень і заспокоює відразу
мило топ то ресурс знаходиться в porsche
rs у нашому тілі я лежатиму на дивані
і там цілий дуба вигадати сама
сексуальна йоржів варіант
лежать і надягання і думати і тобто
перед і наміру не треба but i про
Зараз обов'язковому що в
цьому є саме травматизація свідомість
намагається вирватися з цього моменту
забути про тіло піти повністю ось це в
інформацію потрібно при буквально
повертати де я що я торкнутися
відчути подихати надивитися
час повертає себе у справжній що
мені зараз потрібно робити що мені зараз і
ще один дуже важливий момент тривога
контролюється коли у тебе є план
складіть усередині 7 тепла на один день
аналітик та з такі плани
нормальний план протягнутої звали ти
поїсть і погодуйте дотягну потім по вийти
кінцю овочі піднято себе погодувати дітей
ну там при брат і нагодувати адитивного
в розумі це а обличчі травня буде вей план
пряма сид все в плані і бачу приводу
допоможе образ і висіла
веселий кульові ти на ви спочатку
продовжують брежнева році думки треба було
всі страхи та ванні у думках
правильності я реальність я небезпека
крім небезпеки і треба супер інспекція
на вч це всіх дражнять і я ясну за
groza за раз про батька страхи або дражнячи
ще страхи зі займись і справам і все за
гро забежим маєш зрозуміло вона
якщо навіть важливо важливим і ще одне
рядки vip раз дорожнього заплутатися тобі
що , чи прийшло для дачі включити оправи
на те, що люди виїхали і або людина з
бойовими ми в тому, що він і там в Україні
народу чомусь і такі менше ось я і
ціну я б вона ж за своїми позиками з
буде соціально така душа пушер
штука історія я проти tasting вчителям
треба розуме тягни ціни яскраво на добрих
rich
буде і думаєш його на такі добрі
чого на віч і варити про війну не вина
хорошого ланцюга що таку внутрішню
поганості
внутрішню поганість і ц а тривожне
розлад взагалі якщо ви посилює
що ви доведете себе до неврозу і толку
з вас взагалі ніякого не буде тому
що взагалі вона базується на будинок на
співчутті та на бажання допомогти та
тому безпорадності тому дуже важливо ще
якраз повертатися в реальність я зробив
такий вибір чому тому що я рятуючи
дитини тому що правильно я рятую
там старих хто ви їх ви жінка з
дітьми виїхати так весь другий момент я
вибирав цю війну ні я не вибирала
добрим я виявився перед фактом я роблю
що я рятую я роблю те що я можу я
рятую світ стоїть нам без батьків там
стає старих дітей 3 я можу
зараз якось допомогти
турбуючись де
який сенс було їде кудись щоб
потім довести себе до психозу взагалі ці
все значить займаючись і дитину робити те
що потрібно і
зв'язуватися щовечора насправді
потрібно один одного підтримувати це як
раз зараз ситуації коли один одного
потрібно переказати нехай маленькі але
хороша новина
відразу мило так то напав на потрібно
домагатися but i ну скажемо так
своїми емоціями в Україні і на мага то
сестра чекати і розум чому так і щось
можеш не страждав дані тренда варти
дати розкраси вони можуть і розробок
як синдбада хочеш допомогти зруби
зруби це
коли того щоб запрацює але
маса парі чеки ти можеш зуби і ти будь
ласкавих було подбати про dota не
обійди волонтери kia
околицях Європи наші люди волонтери види
іншу куди треба відразу митри бога і
кумису раз обсе і чого і movano
що хайти бдд рахунок і
не дієш якщо ти не дієш якщо
ти зупиняєшся і ти сидиш і тоді
починається невроз з цієї дії або
знайди собі робилися це не знаєш що
робити зроби щось потрібно вона
співпереживати як би і психовати цим ти
нікому не допоможеш я
одразу мілана то ряду ж така махіна
убоге харчування вам задам але може
звучить тому що тому, що натиснули така
велика за раз і ціна з приводу кабачків
був у були на фронті нібито ти не
по маточці
ти сказати
відразу не ти їй мови я кімоно можемо
змінити такі кеди кінцеві дані
називаються це життя смерть і дітей не
потрібно це приховувати
треба сказати, що твій батько
героїчно загинув на війні захищаючи нас з
тобою
він був великою людиною і створити про нього
neff тому що тіло а толку пішло від духу
не fat сам він все одно залишається ви
зрозумійте, а батько нікуди не йде з життя
він назавжди залишається в голові
тому потрібно про це пам'ятати і потрібно
дитині допомогти з цього моменту тобто
сказати про факт
якщо є можливість дати можливість
попрощатися та
пройти крізь цю on бо часто
буває уникає цих моментів немає це
важко але це необхідно щоб
у людини та штабі дитини сталося як
ніби є на завершення і
найголовніше треба пам'ятати що в розумі
батько нікуди не йде навпаки
стає ще більш живим тому
цього моменту треба говорити про нього
тільки хороше
наповнювати спогадами тільки добрий
збирає таке загалом є таке але
різні традиції але є речі батька є
те, що ми робили разом, це все стане
цінним та пам'ятними з роками буде
ставати все ціннішими все ціннішими все
ціні
ось такі
відразу мене тільки вона зажадала року
таких з там довгих історії з гвинтом то
їсти приїхав путін кредо нозі вимагали
ось і
добра наталія спілкуватися з чим буду
траволти місяці скажемо так на руки про
місяці на скейті з великою часткою
ймовірності c
медицина психі кольорових людей і
розкинуться зараз проживати
я хочу сказати ще
заходь гасити, а нам і борщі, і нам його
стане проживаємо атаки та
а ми тут у нашому проекті ось cth
переживала і пекло і
тато та
переслідуванням десь 70 відсотків людей
переживає одно
подібного роду
одужує самостійно
відновлюється психіка 30 відсотків
людей дійсно травмуються тому
що у людей різного рівня тривожності
переклад як би як вам пояснити у мене
тут просто вибачте ось допустимо це
градусник.
уявіть собі таку шкалу від нуля до
ста все кожного це все людей ось цей
рівень тривожності
наприклад і розділіть на 4 частини перша
чверть це люди взагалі спокійні і в
звичайного життя і в стресі коли
виникає стрес вони теж зберігають
спокій
2 чверть це люди які у звичайній
життя спокійні окуляри якщо стрес вони
дадуть реакцію, але дуже досить швидко
вони приходять головок спокійному стані
третя чверть
це люди які у звичайному житті вже
такі як би тривожні зазвичай як будуть
клієнти кажуть пацієнти кому
потрібна тобто вони у звичайному житті такі
як був всі стривожені чому тому
що не була така історія не плач не
хворі але взагалі ніби і є
розлади та й до цього є
передумови тобто це сім'ї цієї
історії важкі і це більшість людей
насправді дуже багато хто дійсно
високо тривожні люди тобто вони у
звичайного життя тривожний але якщо стрес
сильні ось їм буде важко
відновлюватися досить важко
найвища чверть це вже як би
кориці до психіатра тобто це люди
які у звичайному житті настільки високі
і тривожно, що у них симптоматика то
є вони можуть бачити чути тобто вони
настільки як би три бога дає сильні
симптоми, що німці їх лікують
медикаментозно та природно не і
оберігають вони дуже й у стресі
абсолютно марно верстат про все
вони не можуть керувати собою тому, що
єдине що відбувається три бога
коли дає стрибок
підключайте саме тілесна
на активність а мислення йде тут
для нашої як і греки адекватності це
називаєте зберегти мислення стримати
емоції під контролем весь час прагне
опускати на сполох опускати
заспокоюватися дуже важко заспокоюється
коли події весь час день за днем
тому як би ви задали правильний
питання людина може витримати б
кілька перших днів я не хочу
сказати які терміни у кожного по-різному
але спочатку психіка дають таку
акумуляцію це все його відчуваєш
енергію бажання діяти діяти
10 потрібно зрозуміти що якщо цей стрес
затягується щось відбувається наступний
момент психіка тому
адаптується тобто змінюється
певним чином під ці
обставини щоб виживати в цих
Але якщо раптом прибрати як
було
Але це буде не зовсім
адекватна людина
тому потрібно прагнути закінчити
війни перемогти якнайшвидше як
якнайшвидше я
просто пам'ятаю історія своїх бабусь
дідуся він edit edit та провини і там історія
про те шуму на ти маєш спраги маках вдома
там мішок з картоплею покараю чим усе
така можна на вали до деформації особи
деформація вона була знання з ж
напевно все я і на поясний шарнір бас
тема бан імам починають працювати носитися
їх їх заспокоює тобто ось тільки ви
розумієте ось форму про що це таке
велика різноманітність цієї сили загалом
для того, щоб нам зберегти
адекватність але вже якнайшвидше
розправитися
буду міг подітися що праведності ми
йшли бойові до
згідно з цим хотів би на встановлення
нагадаємо і так звук на завершать і на
позитиві я знаю ти таки
мотивашка хороших обожнювання вигляд вас для
всіх українців та кізару склянку
апокаліптичний позитивізм
так добра Наталія навіть вам дякую за
1000 взяла участь у нашому устріми я
пам'ятаю почнеться буду навіть щурів новим
багатим людям вік шон exim завалить
максиму за раз переживаемую від я хочу
здатися вам ваші люди не ми руну і
вас покарають через здоров'я bespeco птахів
цю азинську піцу чоловіка та слава
україні знову граємо зламаємо та силах
народи стоїть сотня мирні вам ночі
друзі за стримами скликано завтра 20 00
гостях буде кістки грубо години до будинку
цього будучи і всім-усім владно
обласному миру та добра таку